[Music]
this new generation is restless and
angry the pacifist is opposed to using
violence but must be prepared to receive
it you're relevant it's Friday night
I've been called
worse your mere presence could derail
the fight for racial Justice in this
country a good 10 15 years on the day
that I was born
black I was also born a homosexual why
was it so important for you to tell
historian in this way well because I
think he's one an astonishing human
being I think he did an extraordinary
thing I mean he did many extraordinary
things but what he clearly was the
organizing brain behind this Monumental
event I mean he laid the groundwork
there have been many marches since then
and and and one of the things which is
what I what what I think is really
incredible about him is the word
activism is used a lot and and and one
of the things that I think he did was he
put the verb in the word activ ISM it's
the details it's the doing it's the
planning it's the thinking it's the
organizing it's the inspiring it's the
pushing and the shoving and not
relenting until you come out on the
other side so I think that's just
phenomenal and also embedded in history
are these phenomenal people who when you
go inside their stories they give you a
power to continue they give you a road
map for what you must do to to take on
the moment that you are living so you
must protect and you must know them and
and and you must celebrate them
absolutely Bruce for you I mean I know
that is part of your mission as well in
many ways Artis activism exactly um you
know for for all of you I I'd love to
hear from you Bruce Antonia Branford as
well your relationship to Bard and what
um how you first found out about his
incredible story there was a moment in
the 9s where the LGBT community knew who
he was and had recognized him as an icon
and so when Lance Black sent me the
script um about four or five years ago I
was deeply excited and knew right away
that it was something I would love to be
a part of um and I assumed that some of
the community would still know him and I
was really surprised to find out that
less people knew him even than had in
the 90s I didn't realize that was a
thing but it it
re made me all the more determined to
try and get this story made and so
happily and fortunately the two people
that I took it to were George C wolf and
Tonia Davis and the rest will hopefully
be bued taking his rightful place in
history abolutely tell me about that
phone call then Tonia when you when you
hear about this I was hi this is Bruce
Cohen um you know I have something I'd
love to share with you please give me a
call and called him back right away and
he said that he and George wolf and
Lance Black Julian Bree had this amazing
screenplay about byard Rustin and I
actually only knew who byard was because
he had received the Medal of Honor from
um my now boss President Obama at the
time that he um bestowed that medal
obviously was president and so I knew of
him but I really didn't know that much I
knew he was a black gay man in the 1960s
who um uh influenced you know Martin
Luther King Jr I had no idea that he
taught that he led that he was um you
know to George's Point um one of the
foremost um activists who never gave up
under any circumstance who paid
attention I knew none of that so um read
the script and and obviously um fell in
love with it right away shared it with
the Obamas who also fell in love with it
right away and um here we are I think
one of the guiding lights for George and
for all of us if not The Guiding Light
was Rustin himself and who he had been
and the type of person that he was and
his wild Charisma his wild ability to
entertain was first and foremost in our
minds and I think we all felt that if we
made a stagi biopic that was only a
history lesson he would leave his grave
and come murder us all we really wanted
to make sure that the film captured the
joyous essence of byard BR I I I don't
want to let you get away either because
of course you and George have a long
history together working together
creating uh beautiful Movie music
so creating beautiful music together
yes so as as you find out tell me about
how you found out about this project and
and what it meant to you to pay tribute
to Bard I knew of him but I didn't know
what I what I now know I can't remember
where I was George called me okay man I
got this project man you in I'm like
yeah I'm in I need music like how much
of the film have you done none I still
need music I'm like here we go it's
starting again so and that's that's our
thing you're going to do it yeah great
send me music okay tell me a little bit
about y'all's thing because that is the
way you work it is sometimes he he sends
you music you haven't shot anything yet
and vice versa you send him footage H
how does this thing work between you two
George when you're doing a project that
is set in the period it you don't want
to be I I I don't want I I want to I
want to immerse myself so fully into the
sound of it I you know reading the books
for this I you know I saw cetti's first
film was shot around this time shadows
and that entered my brain and then Sammy
Davis Jr was in a movie called a man
called Adam which was Sicily Tyson's
first movie and I watched that and sweet
smell of success so I so I absorbed a
lot of the of the popular culture just
to just to get my version of what 1960s
New York mostly New York and then and
then DC would would would would look
like and there's my aesthetic and then
there's the aesthetic of the time period
and I'm sort of mixing them up so that
therefore what I come up with feels for
La of B words authentic but not
slavishly devoted to it that it has that
it has the spark of of of of unknown and
possibility but it feels grounded in the
time well I I would be remiss to mention
you know folks who walk into the room
and everyone's head turns Coleman
Domingo uh just an incredible force and
that
performance tell me for each of you what
is a moment of Coleman's performance
that really stands out I got to
appreciate his uh his his his
understanding and his level of spec the
level of specificity I think that he
brings to to characters is is really
incredible I don't have one particular
moment that stands out I just loved him
from the moment he first comes into the
film I mean he was just electric he was
electric to me and and uh you know that
that very first scene you know know your
power you know who said you're not our
man you know it's just like wow you know
and so when I wrote that that opening
thing I it was him because there's that
scene where he says know your
power and then Martin has little Sly
smile and I'm like yeah okay and it
really did Inspire that opening Q music
just flows out from there Tonia what
about for you one of my favorite moments
in the film one of my favorite moments
of Coleman in the film is um the night
after the first party party at
Michelle's he and Tom um have their
evening together um which is illegal at
the time and uh the next morning um as
he's drawing and coming up with the
ideas and all the young all the young
people come in in the moment of angelic
troublemakers when I'm watching that
that is the moment when I see Coleman
embody him in this way that also feels
so honest to who Coleman is who um was
such a leader such a a um a troublemaker
rabble Rouser Mischief maker in the best
possible way um with all the young
people and so when I watch that scene it
always always lean in and I always think
to use branford's word this is
electric it it's it's interesting
because I you know I I you know I've
been talking a lot about the film and
then at one point to day I went oh
that's right we work together in maren's
black bottom and so in many respects it
was like preparing for this moment and
and and and
crafting a a a landscape of where where
we evolved a language and a way of
working together and and then and then
bringing on all these astonishing other
actors who are playing all these
astonishing human beings who were so
ferociously committed to the cause who
felt this sense of unbelievable
responsibility and this is connected to
Coleman and this is connected to a
McDonald and Jeffrey Wright and
everybody the in the beginning the young
girl whose face you first see who was
sitting at the counter and the ketchup
slides down her face just we it was one
of the last one of one of the last the
last series of scenes that we
did and I was I was you know and and I
was going up and I was talking to her
and I was saying um you know we we're
going to make sure that you're safe and
this and talking to her she says I don't
care we got to get it right I don't care
what do do what you have to do we got to
we have got to get this moment right
that girl sitting there with the catchup
sliding down her face brought her
vulnerability for that moment and the
moment is so true and so simple and so
pure and you you see it you see it and
you feel it and I think that that the
one of the wonders of Coleman's
performance one of The Wonder of all the
performances in the film and I'm very
proud of of of the cast for that reason
because you know we had a rehearsal
period we do all we had a rehearsal
period And I'd rehearse with them every
day before we would shoot anything is
the the the purity of heart and con and
not just the talent but the purity of
heart and conviction and sense of
responsibility qualities which bu you
know had oozing out of every poor every
single day and on the crew and everybody
working on it brought that same sense of
responsibility and commitment and focus
and generosity and heart and and it was
it was a glorious thing to be a part of
and a glorious things to help nurture
and create an environment where to allow
that to happen well thank you all for
doing whatever it takes thank you all
for joining us thank you all for coming
and just a reminder Rustin in theaters
on November 3rd and streaming on Netflix
beginning November 17th thank you thank
you thank you very
much